Zoro is a sword god who has become one
of the ABSOLUTE STRONGEST FIGHTERS in the
entire story with his top-tier swordsmanship
and insane will power. But you cannot deny
that he has fallen behind Luffy because
of his captain’s incredible devil fruit
powers. So you know what? To even
the playing field we are going to
give Zoro a simply broken devil fruit to
see just how overpowered he would become.
And before we see all the
insane changes to Zoro’s story,
which includes an incredible twist about a
certain black-haired swordswomen, we first
have to ask the most IMPORTANT QUESTION:
Which devil fruit is perfect for Zoro?
Which if you ask this question online, many common
fruits that people want to give Zoro are pretty
good options. These include Mr. 1’s Dice fruit,
which turns the user into a literal blade human,
or Nico Robin’s flower fruit which would allow him
to sprout more arms to fight with, but honestly,
both of these powers don’t add that much to Zoro’s
current fighting style. I mean why does Zoro need
to turn his arm into a blade when he already
has three ridiculously powerful swords to fight
with? Likewise, sure you could say that if Zoro
had more arms he could wield even more swords,
kinda like this octopus dude here, but then again
he pretty much already has this power when he uses
his ultimate Ashura technique, which gives him
more arms and umm… mouths. Which is actually kinda
hilarious now that I saw it out loud. But anyway,
now that he has unlocked his advanced conqueror’s
haki, we’ll probably be seeing him bust out
this technique way more often in the future.
So no Dice fruit, and no Flower fruit. So which
one is it? Personally, I think the Gravity fruit
would be absolutely devastating when combined
with Zoro’s sword skills, but since we’ve already
seen what this fruit can do in the hands of a
master swordsman, let’s skip this one as well.
This brings us to our final candidates, which are
going to COMPLETELY BLOW YOUR MIND. And the first
one is a brand new devil fruit that I completely
made up while researching for this video. However,
familiar, that’s because you might have heard this
name during discussions about the Wano arc. That’s
because he is the real-world inspiration for one
of the samurai Oden’s legendary swords: Ame no
Habikiri. And even though Zoro doesn’t currently
own this sword, I still think it’s fitting since
Susanoo was a mythical swordsman god. However,
the MAIN POWER that is associated with Susanoo
is the power of storms, which means that if Zoro
ate this fruit, then he would unlock the ability
to summon wind, rain, lightning, and tons of other
weather based powers. And if you know ANYTHING
about one piece, then you should realize what a
truly OP power this would be in a world covered in
oceans, especially if he combined these elemental
abilities into his sword fighting techniques.
But then I got to thinking that this fruit
wouldn’t change the one piece story a ton because
it doesn’t exist in One Piece, which is how
I ultimately decided that THE PERFECT devil
fruit for Zoro is the legendary Darkness Logia
fruit. And OH MY GOD, this is going to change
EVERYTHING. First of all, this power gives Zoro
the ability to send out waves of darkness that
can suck in anything including buildings,
land, people, and much more to be crushed
in his darkness and then spit back out. But
that’s not the most important power for Zoro,
because the number one most incredible ability
this would give him is to suck in devil fruit
users and basically turn off their powers while he
is touching them. Which is an INSANE ability for
our green haired swordsman. And even though this
fruit makes him absorb all the damage he receives,
Zoro is such a high-durability tank anyway
that this downside isn’t really a problem.
Now we get to the most mind-blowing part
of giving Zoro the Darkness devil fruit,
which is all of the TRULY WILD changes it will
have on the story. And I personally thought it
would be pretty boring just to give him a
power boost and follow the normal storyline
because honestly that would mean everything
is just way too easy for the straw hats. So
instead I dug deep and figured out some actual
changes that just make way too much sense,
which includes a twist I’ve never
heard in any one piece discussion EVER.
And we’ll start with Zoro as a child, where
much like Luffy he has somehow accidentally
eaten his devil fruit. Which means that
he’ll be practicing swordsmanship in this
dojo in the East Blue while also learning how
to control his wildly destructive devil fruit
powers. Hopefully they have good insurance.
But now for the most shocking twist of all,
let’s imagine that during this period Darkness
Zoro somehow defeats the most powerful enemy
in the story… the stairs. And by defeating this
legendary monster, Zoro’s childhood friend Kuina
gets to live. All jokes aside, Kuina being
alive and *cough* not as Tashigi is going to
have massive implications for the rest of the
story. So now let’s skip ahead several years,
where Zoro and his equally powerful
friend are ready to set out to sea.
At this point, I think Zoro would have gotten
much better at swordsmanship and mastered the
basics of his devil fruit, while Kuina is just
a super powerful swordswoman. And of course
they still duel each other constantly, but at
this point I have to believe Zoro would have at
least defeated her a few times. Although I have to
point out that he probably doesn’t allow himself
to use his devil fruit whenever he fights a pure
swordsman. You know, the whole bushido thing.
So they both set off for adventure, but
tragedy is going to strike IMMEDIATELY.
That’s because we all know Zoro can’t
follow directions to save his life,
so when they split up to take down
some pirates on a random island,
Darkness Zoro somehow ends up on a completely
different island and is lost from his childhood
friend. This unfortunately means that they aren’t
going to reunite for quite some time, but just
wait for the unbelievable turn of events when
they do find each other in just a few minutes.
At this point, Zoro will still be a bounty hunter.
And because of his awesome darkness powers, he can
easily suck groups of pirates into his darkness
pocket dimension and then spit them back out to
collect the bounties at a marine base. And this
combination of his incredible sword skills and
his devil fruit abilities absolutely skyrockets
his reputation SO MUCH that the world government
offers him a position as a Warlord. Which he
normally wouldn’t accept because he wouldn’t
want to be ordered around by the marines, but
on the other hand he might think that accepting
the position would earn him a shot at dueling
the world’s strongest swordsman, Mihawk. So
let’s assume that Zoro becomes a Warlord and gets
his wish to square off against Mihawk. But man,
this was a very bad idea, because Darkness Zoro
would get absolutely destroyed, just like in
the original story. Even if he used his devil
fruit, which I don’t think he would, Mihawk is
just in a different galaxy in terms of skills at
this point, so Zoro would be helplessly crushed.
Which would leave him absolutely furious,
but he would probably now have even more
motivation to grow stronger. But after
some time to heal up, he ghosts the World
Government since he already got his shot
at Mihawk. Then the government would most
likely strip away his Warlord status and label
him a pirate. Hmm, well that didn’t last long.
Now at this point he would probably head into the
Grand Line so he can fight against strong pirates,
but come on this is Zoro we are talking
about, so THE ONLY WAY he EVER makes it
to the Grand Line is if he finds a talented
navigator. So let’s say he randomly picks up
Navigator Manny over here, who doesn’t really
care about fighting but sure loves to drink,
and heads up Reverse Mountain into the Grand
Line. Which if you haven’t realized by now,
this means that Zoro completely missed
out on joining the Straw Hat crew. But
don’t worry because he is going
to meet up with them VERY SOON.
Damn, this story is about to get weird.
Now that Darkness Zoro is in the Grand Line with
his Navigator Manny, he is going to ABSOLUTELY
CRUSH some strong opponents to take out his
frustration at losing to Mihawk. However,
remember that even though the World Government
has labeled him a pirate, his only true goal is
to become the world’s strongest swordsman. So I
can imagine him seeking out any strong pirate who
is also a swordsman such as Trafalgar Law or Basil
Hawkins who are members of the Worst Generation,
and even strong marines such as Captain T-Bone.
And while Darkness Zoro should win these battles,
he wouldn’t care about turning in the
pirates for bounties since he has already
been labeled a pirate at this point so he
couldn’t make any money off the bounties.
But all this means that Darkness Zoro’s
name is spreading around Paradise,
and it is inevitable that he will eventually
meet up with the Straw Hat Crew. Perhaps he
sails over to Alabasta to fight Mr. 1 only to
find that the blade man has already been defeated
by the Straw Hat Crew, and in particular,
the Straw Hat’s newest swordswomen, Kuina.
Yup, that’s right. Zoro’s spot on the crew was
taken by none other than his childhood friend,
who was recruited by Luffy sometime during the
East Blue Saga. So while Zoro is pissed about not
being able to fight Mr. 1, he is SUPER EXCITED
to see his long lost friend. So of course he
greets her by challenging her to a duel, and who
knows at this point who would come out on top,
but whatever the outcome in the end Zoro would
probably end up partying with the Straw Hat crew.
But these reunited friends are not going to
be able to enjoy their happy meeting for long.
Because while Zoro has been going around making a
name for himself, you might have wondered what’s
going on with the original owner of the Darkness
fruit. Oh boy, get ready for this one. Because
remember that Blackbeard spent literal decades
searching for this fruit while on the Emperor
Whitebeard’s crew. So once he hears that the
Darkness fruit is being used by Zoro, he is
instantly going to come after the green haired
swordsman. And while Blackbeard might actually
surprise you with his strength - remember he did
give young shanks his scars - I’m not too sure if
Blackbeard would win a straight up fight. Which
means he’ll do what he always does. Set a trap.
And there are many ways that this could go,
but here’s a scenario that I think makes
a lot of sense. As Zoro and Manny sail
around getting closer to the New World,
they suddenly get a very strange call on their
transponder snail that instantly sends Zoro into
a rampage. It turns out that Blackbeard has
kidnapped Zoro’s childhood sensei, Koushirou,
and is holding him hostage on a nearby island. So
Zoro and Manny instantly sail to the island and
find Koushirou trapped in a cage. Of course, Zoro
slices through the bars, but as he does Blackbeard
pops up behind him and traps Zoro in seastone
handcuffs. Now Manny tries to defend his captain,
but he’s not much of a fighter, which means that
Blackbeard has a free shot at the weakened Zoro.
This is not looking good at all until suddenly
Blackbeard’s pistol gets chopped in half as
Kuina turns up to save her longtime rival and
father. And as she frees Zoro from the handcuffs,
she reveals that she had heard about her
missing father and was tracking him down
all this time. Then together they
destroy Blackbeard and then depart
the island. This means Koushirou can go
home, Kuina goes back to the Straw Hats,
and an embarrassed Zoro heads out to find
some pirates to take out his frustration.
So this turn of events means no more Blackbeard is
going to MASSIVELY change the rest of the story,
and also means that you should subscribe to the
channel for more one piece content like this.
Now let’s jump ahead a few years because at this
point there was no Marineford and no timeskip,
so Zoro is going to continue to seek out strong
opponents to get stronger. But there is one major
question that we simply must answer. Because
remember that during the timeskip Zoro laid
down his pride to ask Mihawk to train him. BUT he
only did this because of his loyalty to Luffy and
the crew. So, would Darkness Zoro still seek out
a swordmaster to train him if he is on his own?
Honestly, I think the answer is no. That means
that he would have to learn haki on his own, which
I think is fairly reasonable for him to do as long
as he is clashing with strong fighters in the New
World. And speaking of strong fighters, he might
run into the Straw Hats and clash with Kuina a few
more times, or I could even see him challenging
other members of the Supernova such as Euastas Kid
and his spinning-blade Vice Captain, Killer,
who he fought in the original story anyway.
Although Kid would be a tough matchup for Zoro
because of his magnetism devil fruit, so Zoro
might have to rely on his darkness powers to win
this matchup. Another very reasonable opponent
for him to have frequent clashes with would be
someone like Vista from the Whitebeard pirates,
who was a strong enough swordsman to clash with
Mihawk during the original war at Marineford.
But since we’re talking about Whitebeard, we
have to mention that this Yonko crew is only
still together because Marineford never occurred.
Which means that Whitebeard is alive, for now.
However, at this point Whitebeard was already
sick and dying, so let’s assume that he does
die from natural causes. This could lead
to the Whitebeard pirates disbanding,
or the much more likely scenario is
that someone like Marco the Phoenix
or Luffy’s childhood friend Ace takes over as
captain. Let’s just say that it is Ace for now.
Now let’s assume that by this point Zoro has
learned haki and possibly even awakened his
conqueror’s haki, so now he is a MAJOR POWERHOUSE
of a fighter. This would definitely allow him to
defeat Vista, and if he were to take him down,
then it is certainly possible that the new
captain Ace would challenge Zoro to a duel. And
now there are a lot of ways that this could go,
however since Ace is a devil fruit user, Zoro is
more than willing to use his devil fruit in this
clash. And honestly, Zoro has a great chance of
taking down Ace even easier than Blackbeard did
in the original story. Because when Blackbeard
sucked in Ace and took away his powers, he could
only punch the fire fruit user, which didn’t do
all that much damage. But Zoro would take this
opportunity to land a major slash on Ace, which
could mean this fight might be over very quickly.
But wow, Darkness Zoro has come a LONG WAY on
his own! I mean we always kinda knew that he was
strong enough to be his own captain, but with this
latest accomplishment he is now considered on par
with Yonko tier characters, even though he doesn’t
have an actual crew of his own, and honestly we
can’t say that he is Yonko level yet anyway,
since Ace was never as strong as Whitebeard.
However, now Zoro has a major problem.
You see, at his current level of strength,
there are very few characters that Zoro can
now truly test himself against. Basically,
only the Marine admirals, the Yonko and
their top commanders, and his longtime
target Mihawk. The problem is that he cannot
find Mihawk and none of the other characters
will just let him walk right in and challenge
them to a fair fight. So he’s kinda stuck,
which leads him to make the TERRIBLE
DECISION to try to fight Kaido in Wano.
Now, we all know it is ridiculously hard
to get into Wano, but let’s imagine that
Navigator Manny has been upgrading his
own skills throughout all this time,
so the pair manage to make it up the waterfalls
into Wano. Zoro of course would want to head
straight to challenge Kaido to a
drinking contest… Oh, wait, no.
A duel, but at this point, Darkness Zoro probably
wouldn’t be able to defeat the king of the beasts.
Even though Zoro can negate devil fruits, Kaido
is still massively powerful, plus he has his
whole crew to back him up, so unfortunately,
Zoro is defeated and thrown into prison.
But despite what you might think, this is actually
THE BEST THING that could have happened to Zoro.
You see, in this prison is this wrinkly old man,
who was the yakuza boss of Wano before Kaido took
over. And when he meets Zoro, they will have
time to fix one of the major downsides of the
original Wano arc, which was the lack of focus on
Zoro’s family history. Because if you didn’t know,
Zoro’s grandmother was originally from Wano
and part of the same Shimotsuki family line
who were daimyos of Wano. Which means that
Zoro is descended from Wano’s royalty,
and his great uncle was even killed by Kaido
when the Yonko took over the country. So
once all this is explained to Zoro, in this
version of the story let’s imagine that Zoro
feels even more anger that his homeland has
been ruined so now he is EXTRA determined to
take down Kaido. Which is perfect timing
because of what is going to happen next.
You see, soon after Zoro is imprisoned, Luffy is
also captured by Kaido. And when these two meet
up in prison, there is no way they are staying
trapped for long. So Zoro breaks out and joins
the raid on Onigashima, where he teams up with
Luffy, Kuina, and the rest of the straw hats to
take down Kaido and Big Mom. Though I’m not too
sure how Luffy and Zoro would team up to fight.
Would they both want to take down Kaido or would
Zoro be fine with battling it out with Big Mom? We
might never know, but one other super important
question we ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO ASK is if Luffy
would have even made it to Wano without Zoro. I
mean, this version of the straw hats have Kuina,
but Zoro’s unbreakable will kept the straw hats
together more than once throughout the story,
so to find out if Luffy would even make
it out of the East Blue without Zoro,
I made an entire video about it
which you can watch right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.